in einem kleinen Haus am Rande von Goris
treffen wir Familie
Gregorian es ist ein KAGes leben seit
sie aus ihrer Heimat Bergkarabach
geflohen sind dieses Haus konnten sie
nur zwischen mieten müssen bald wieder
ausziehen nach zuhause fühlt es sich
nicht
an sie sind zu ne Mutter in war früher
Verkäuferin aber hier im ländlichen
armenien ist dieit
es gibt kaum
Jobs ohne Arbeit ist es schwer wir
bekommen staatliche Unterstützung aber
wollen uns nicht darauf verlassen
sondern einen Job finden und uns selbst
ernähren wir wollten schon immer lieber
arbeiten und für unsere Kinder
sorgen die Kinder sind in berabach
geboren in zeigt un Fotos ihre Freunde
Nachbarn alle
musstenlien die Region angegriffen und
erobert hat sie träumen davon
zurückzukehren auch wenn das fast
ausgeschlossen
ist es war viel besser dort mit meinen
Freunden wir waren zusammen am gleichen
Ort hier ist alles unbekannt für
mich sie leben in Goris wo im
septemberus Flüchtlinge
ankamen viele hängen immer noch hier
fest
ohne
Perspektive ein paar Straßen weiter
rüsten Sie sich für den nächsten Krieg
obwohl die Wunden nach dem Kampf um
Bergkarabach längst nicht verheilt sind
junge Männer werden für den Wehrdienst
eingezogen Z Jahre weg von zu Hause und
die Angst dass sie bald gegen den Feind
kämpfen
müssen sie können selbst sehen es sind
viele hierher gekommen natürlich machen
wir uns Sorgen aber das Land muss
geschützt werden
die Armenier kennen es nicht
anders nach mehreren Kriegen gegen
Aserbaidschan gehört der Kampf fürs
Vaterland fast zur
DNA auch wenn die armenische Armee der
hochgerüsteten aserbaidschanischen klar
unterlegen
ist wie Helden werden sie
verabschiedet
wir fahren in den Süden des Landes neuer
Brennpunkt im Konflikt zwischen den seit
Jahrzehnten verfeindeten
Völkern denn Aserbeidschan will eine
Landverbindung zwischen dem Kernland und
der esklave nach hitchewan eine Straße
mittenurch
Armenien für Güter und Personenverkehr
ohne armenische
Grenzkontrollen doch erst kürzlich
erhebt der autokratische Herrscher
Aserbaidschans Ansprüche auf den
gesamten Süden
Armeniens dort in sunik treffen wir
makatiovanisan er hat fast sein ganzes
Leben in diesem kleinen Dorf nahe der
aserbaidschanischen Grenze verbracht 61
Jahre viele Menschen leben hier nicht
mehr das Dorf stirbt
aus MAK nimmt uns mit nach Hause wo er
mit seiner Frau lebt die Kinder sind
ausgezogen er baut Obst und Gemüse
an hält ein paar
Hühner normalerweise bringt ihn wenig
aus der Ruhe doch dass Armenien und
Aserbaidschan seit kurzem zumindest
offiziell wieder über Frieden verhandeln
regt ihn massiv
auf welcher Friedensprozess soll das
sein wir haben gesehen wie die
aserbeidschaner Bergkarabach ethnisch
säuberten und friedliche Zivilisten
töteten ich kann mir keinen Frieden
vorstellen wir fragen ihn was die
Alternative
ist wir würden Frauen und Kinder in die
Berge schicken wenn sie angreifen der
Rest von uns wird schießen was können
wir sonst noch tun glaubt ihr ich werde
weglaufen niemals aus Junik rennt
niemand
Weg die Konsequenzen eines
aseridsanischen Angriffs wären fatal
auch
wirtschaftlich Region sunik grenzt auch
an den Iran am Übergang treffen wir die
armenischen Zollbeamten der Handel
zwischen Armenien und Iran sei eine
Lebensader für das ganze Land sagen
sie das Handelsvolumen zwischen Iran und
Armenien ist groß und wächst weiter das
ist sehr wichtig für unsere Wirtschaft
jedes Jahr sehen wir mehr und mehr
Lastwagen aus dem Iran die alle
möglichen Arten von Waren
transportieren wirtschaftlicher
Aufschwung ist nicht selbstverständlich
in dem eh armen Land sowie überhaupt
wenig selbstverständlich ist für die
Armenier Frieden Sicherheit eine
Perspektive niemand weiß das besser als
die Flüchtlinge in Goris Inna Gregorian
und ihre Kinder finden Trost in der
Kirche wir wurden hier zwar herzlich
empfangen aber ich werde deprimiert wenn
ich daran denke kein zu Hause zu haben
ich lebe in einem Fremden Haus
vielleicht bin ich deshalb manchmal
gestresst und traurig wenn ich ein
eigenes Heim hätte könnte ich mit ganzem
Herzen hier ankommen rum sie zünden
Kerzen an für die Toten die sie in ihrer
Heimat zurücklassen mussten und für die
Soldaten die jungen Männer die womöglich
den Krieg noch vor sich haben dass die
nächste Generation in Frieden lebt daran
glaubt hier kaum
jemand
ه